Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
formin.
Muslim.
This narration is on the authority of
Abi
known to most
as
ari
which directly translates to
Su the Roman.
But Su Arumi was not Roman.
He was originally from Iraq and as we
see here his father's name is Sin which
is an Arabic name
rather he was referred to as Sarumi
because during the
expansions
of the Roman Empire he was captured
and
taken as a slave and he was sold as a
slave.
later to be sold to some of the
chieftains of Mecca where he then
resided until the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam was appointed as a prophet.
Because of this, the name kind of stuck.
It's not his origin, but it's where he
came from. He came from the Roman front.
So, he's referred to as Suib Ai. a lot
of
so he was Arab and slaves during
the time of Jahia and pre-Islamic and
postIslamic times were not
necessarily of any ethnicity or any
race. They were whoever they could get
their hands on. Whoever the stronger
dominating party could get their hands
on, they would take them and they would
sell them into slavery. We see that
Yuisam
was sold
and purchased as a slave.
And in the Quran and here we have Su
Arumi, an Arab. However, he was sold
into slavery.
And
the true difference in pre-Islamic and
post-Islamic
is that in pre-Islamic times, a slave
had many many ways of becoming a slave.
If you could imagine with me
a triangle of a pyramid or if you could
imagine with me a cone, right?
So in pre-Islamic times
that cone was upside down. It was an
upside down. There were many many many
ways a person could become a slave. Many
ways. But there was only one way that
the person could be free
and that is if his master freed him.
That's the only way.
And some of them were even left behind
as
as part of inheritance and would make
generations of slaves.
However, Islam
turned that upside down, turned it
around,
right? So now the cone is
the tip side up. How is that? There's
only one way a person can become a
slave. Only one. What way is that?
Prisoner of war. That's it. That's the
only way. So, no more slaves
except those who are captured on the
battlefield actively fighting
against
Islam and the Muslim.
However, the ways to be free became many
many ways to become free. Person could
buy himself. A person could be freed by
his master. A person could purchase
himself. A person could be and the
masters are encouraged to free a slave.
Almost at every turn,
we are encouraged to free slaves in our
religion. Even if even if it's as much
as
breaking an oath or swearing to do
something and failing to do so, first
thing, first course of action, free a
slave, right? A person
messes up and and breaks his fast during
the day of Ramadan, free a slave. a
person, you know, and so the the
amount of ways that a slave can become
free became very numerous. And the ways
that a person could by law become a
slave are only one way. And so this
helped to progressively without shocking
the local economy and without shocking
the and without shocking the slaves
themselves because if you could imagine
thousands and thousands of slaves
immediately becoming free.
Many of them would have preferred to go
back to their masters because now they
have to fend for themselves. It's a very
complex issue and so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala very
progressively
urged towards the freedom of slaves
without placing a burden neither on the
master nor on the slave. So Abu Su Abu
Yahban
Sui he was from Iraq was taken as a
slave later brought to Mecca and he is
one of the first companions of the
prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam.
And now
he narrates that the messenger of Allah.
Wasam said
the affair of the believer is a very
curious affair.
All of his affair. Anything that happens
to him, anything that doesn't happen to
him, anything that he comes to succeed
in, anything that he doesn't come to
succeed in, all of it, all of his affair
is good for him.
Yet, this is only true for the believer
and his affair, the one who believes.
How so? He says in
if he is given something good, something
to make him happy, he thanks Allah
and that then becomes best for him and
good for him.
And yet if he is afflicted with a
difficulty
he is patient
and that then turns that difficulty
into good for him. So no matter what the
believer cannot be
won over, one against by a shaitan.
No matter what is thrown at him, it is
good for him.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam says and this is not for anyone
except for the believer. The disbeliever
loses on both fronts. If he gets a good
then he is not thankful
and that turns that good thing into a
responsibility that he failed to uphold
which is gratitude. And if he is
afflicted with a difficulty and he is
patient he's not rewarded for his
patience. So it is pure difficulty for
him. However the believer
all of his affair is good for him. This
narration was collected by im Muslim
in his authentic compilation. We ask
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to teach us
patience and wisdom. We ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to teach us the
secrets and the wisdoms of his book and
the sunnah of his prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
Alhamdulillah.